he is the co-host of usa network's
competition
series cannonball a season one finale is
tomorrow
uh september 3rd 8pm eastern on usa
the wwe superstar the miz back here on
the rich eisen show how are you bud
well i was a lot better until i started
hearing you talk about pittsburgh seeing
that i'm a cleveland browns
you know what no i don't want them to
have leonard fournette because i don't
want them to do well
i am a cleveland browns fan through and
through we have all the potential
to win the afc north you look at baker
mayfield now he has a line
that he is able to stand behind and
throw to odell throw to jarvis throw to
austin hooper their new tight end that
they paid a lot of money for
and if they're if they're all covered
guess what i got nick chubb and i got
kareem hunt
the cleveland browns are going to the
super bowl
whoa we expected you to come out of the
chute
we expected you to go you know a top
rope when it came to the
cleveland browns super bowl you just
you just you just use the sb word i use
the sb word and i use it quite a bit
every single year about the cleveland
browns because i always feel like
i am the ultimate cleveland browns fan
where i say it's going to happen
i believe it's going to happen and then
something happens where it doesn't
but this is our year we got a coach that
knows an offense that knows how to deal
make baker midfield the
the quarterback that we know he is i'm
excited about this season i'm not
excited to see where
leonard fournette goes because i do
think that pittsburgh dealer should give
him an offer
but i don't want him to go there because
i think leonard fournette is a very good
running back
by the way i don't get why running backs
are like so like
not looked at as as as good like i mean
you get devonte freeman doesn't even
have a team
like i mean come on how does this guy
not have a team i'm just telling you
running backs these days man it just
uh it it is a very difficult position
to stay in and you know i
i saw a stat from nfl
media nfl network nfl media groups of
crack research staff that got tweeted
out since 2016
drafting out of all the positions
drafted
in the top five or top 10 one of the two
it's significant
um to add wins to a season a team's
total from one year to the next
running back was number one four and a
half wins
and i think part of that is you know
when you take a look at well you look at
trent richardson and cleveland brown
you understand no but the the other way
around though i mean
you fournette what he did when he was
drafted and what jacksonville they damn
near went to the super bowl i
the stat may be skewed but all i'm
saying is that
the running back coming out of college
is
always going to be taken over somebody
that needs to get paid
it seems like these days mm-hmm and it's
interesting it's interesting because i
look at some of the rookies that are out
there today like
you know kansas city's got their rookie
and people are taking him
high rounds in fantasy football i'm a
little weary
you know because i mean not everyone's
at stake on barkley you know
coming out of college so i'm a little
weary on you know running backs rookie
running backs whenever i'm looking at
fantasy football
the miz here on the rich eisen show
again uh cannonball which we'll talk
about uh has a season one
finale tomorrow on usa at 80 string time
uh let's talk fantasy uh
i assume you saw the uh the draft list
and draft order for the alice in chains
celebrity fantasy league that uh this
show and you
are participating every year with jerry
cantrell on behalf of charity i assume
you saw that
uh you know every every time i look
every year i go okay
it doesn't matter where i am yes in in
it whether it's one two and three we
know who who's gonna be taken
but you know in the middle part you you
kind of go i always go running back
like it's it's gonna be very i'm gonna i
have six people until uh
until i uh until i pick a right wide
receiver which survivors here will be
michael thomas
but i have six people in front of them
before i even think about taking a wide
receiver because
i always feel running backs go down
really fast and you need
to get you know your elite runners going
and they're going to give you the most
value a lot of people think lamar
jackson
patrick mahomes i'm not a qb guy i wait
long
like i'm looking at matt stafford as my
quarterback this year and i'm looking at
him at like the 10th round
maybe 12th round i don't know um so that
that's kind of the way i skew my my
fantasy football and i do pretty well at
it let me tell you
no i uh you look uh ms i i know you do
well um the reason why i bring this up
about the draft order
is your third overall um
we're second overall so
how much to not take nick chubb second
overall
oh i'm i'm definitely not taking nick
chubb uh that early if he comes around
back to me
in the second round 100 but one two and
three in my book
are christian mccaffrey taequan barkley
and zeke
those are your three those are your
three top players so whoever you
don't take out of those three is who i'm
taking
no i i look because you have to
understand
like obviously you do at cleveland
browns you i know they're gonna run the
ball
that's what they're going to do right
it's literally that that's what they but
they also have kareem hunt and kareem
hunt
is is an elite level running back and so
is nick chubb
so they're going to be splitting the
ball a little bit here and there that
that makes me a little nervous
is is are they going to be able to split
the ball enough i think they're going to
run the ball enough to where
you're going to have two elite running
backs but
it kind of makes me a little weary so uh
how do you like watching dallas cowboys
games
uh you know it's okay it's not like
watching a cleveland browns game no but
i'm i'll tell you what i'm enjoying hard
knocks right now
okay um you know i love seeing los
angeles i love seeing the sofi
stadium um i love seeing the in-depth
coverage of
of nfl players on on what they're doing
how do they prepare
how they get ready with their
motivations like with wwe whenever i'm
wrestling like
you have to have an immense amount of
focus when you're in that ring and i
like to see
other athletes and how they get prepared
like i look at i look at every sport
whether it's major league baseball i
even get golf
and i see how how people focus and lock
in i watched that uh the
documentary with michael jordan and i
was so amazed like
because sometimes i would i would be
like god i kind of do the same thing
like sometimes whenever i need
motivation i'll make something up in my
head
to give me that motivation and i'm and
literally
i do that like when jordan said like
when they were like yeah
she said something about a guy said
something to him and
the guy never said anything to him he
just needed that to
motivate him to do well and to beat
everybody up and i was like oh all right
that's what i do i kind of do that same
thing yeah maybe i'm like michael jordan
maybe i'm comparing myself to the
greatest nba player ever but you know
whatever
you know what do it man i like it that's
that
you speak it into existence man that's
the way it should be the miz here
on the rich eisen show let's talk about
cannonball how much fun are you
and uh having it sure looks like you're
having a blast watching people
you know just just eat it all the time
i love it like i i you know whenever a
a network comes to you and says look we
just want you to be you and have fun
like wait what you just want me to be me
and have fun you're not going to like
restrict me or tell me what to do no
just do
do you and entertain us and literally
that's exactly what
cannonball does like in this world that
we live in right now with all the
conflict and drama that's happening
i feel like people just need an hour to
escape
everything that's going on in their
reality and kind of just
sit down with their family and watch a
show that entertains them and cannonball
is definitely that show our finales
thursday
uh usa network 8 7 central and honestly
it's one of those shows
that it's you know it's laugh out loud
comedy and
it's fun it's competitive and there's a
lot of crashes
i mean we call it cannonball but there's
no cannonballs it's a lot of more belly
flops
is there any um i guess obstacle or
attraction however you want to use it uh
on cannonball that you yourself would
even
think twice about attempting no i wanted
to do each and every one of them but
they wouldn't let me
but i think then if we get a next season
which i think we will because
a lot of people have been talking about
it yeah i definitely 100
want to do the mega slide i want to do
every single challenge they're all fun i
mean we have this one that's called the
human dart
a guy goes down 100 foot mega slag going
about 60 miles an hour
flies off of it going 80 feet in the air
and has to hit a target
and you have to hit it with your body
and so it creates a lot of smashes and a
lot of hilarity and it's one of those
ones that i kind of want to do
that's great and again the season finale
tomorrow i think you're going to get a
second season
um me too it is it's a popular show and
uh you know usa at eight eastern time
everyone should check it out
the season finale tomorrow night heart
of hearts is
harder hearts yeah browns seriously
super bowl you said i i know that a
broken clock is going to be right at
least once in nfl season
but seriously do you think i mean what
do you what do you have for me here
i honestly i truly believe that the
browns have all the pieces like tell me
why
i think the only reason that people can
come up with why because we all have all
the talent it's the chemistry
and the lock-in on a new coach if it's
not this year it's next year in my
opinion and if it's not
there's something wrong with this team
because it has all the talent like you
look at it and
name another team that has more talent
than this team
tampa you think so um
i mean yeah we could we could we could
we could definitely
say i mean i mean where you know you
asked the question i'll answer it i i
i brady and baker mayfield you know i
know they did
the nfl 100 commercial together with all
the rings
um that's that's the quarterback spot uh
i do love o'dell and juice is a
remarkable at wide receiver but evans
and godwin
were the first uh tandem um at wide
receiver on the same team to make the
same pro bowl
since larry fitzgerald and anquan bolden
about a decade ago
um we could go on i mean gronk
at the tight end position and oj howard
i mean you're you're literally looking
at like a team like two teams that are
like
poised you you think do you think that
tampa could win the the super bowl yes i
do
okay so why not the browns if you're
literally comparing you're going oh the
browns are a little
like they have all the talent like
you're you're comparing apples and
oranges
well here's the thing miss and so why
not the brown because i don't know
brady well yeah that's number one but
and i am not a and brockman you can back
me up here i am not a baker mayfield
hater i'm not one of these guys that
goes on
the air and bashes him just to make sure
that i get
uh clicks or i get attention paid and
hope that he shows up on the show
so i can take it from him to prove that
i'm not afraid of saying what i say
about him
even though it's thoroughly unwarranted
just because he's walking
just because he's walking up to a set on
a cell phone after a game to check out
on who texted him i mean you know what i
mean like i
i am not all in on baker mayfield with
the exception of last year was a
thorough disappointment
something was amiss you could say i know
you pointed out that the offensive line
is better this year we'll see if that's
what it is
i i just hope for your sake that he
takes a step forward
and does improve that maybe the coach
last year wasn't the right one for
him this one will be better for him and
he's coached up
i'm just concerned about his level of
consistency if you really want to talk
about winning the afc
and making a super bowl when you've got
mahomes and the chiefs looking the way
they look the ravens and lamar jackson
looking the way they look you've got
your
your hands are full i definitely
definitely have my hands full but
i i'm an optimist i literally look at
browns every year and i think this is it
uh but i've been talking to a lot of
people like one of my buddies is uh you
know
a radio host uh for brown's daily and he
tells me
gives me scoops every single day about
how the browns are doing how are they
looking how are they clicking
and he tells me he's like look this this
team there's something about him this
year
that there's a little bit of electricity
here so i'm like oh i can't wait to hear
it and see it
well man uh i mean so parma ohio that's
your hometown right that's where you're
from
yeah right out of parma ohio and so this
is
so are you are you a reds two a buckeye
and the whole thing are you throwing
i am not a i'm a cleveland indians fan i
am a
cleveland cavaliers fan when the cavs
won uh
the the championship i i i mean it was
one of those things that like cleveland
needed that
and uh and it was it's one of those
moments that i'll remember and people
always ask like were you mad when lebron
left and i honestly said no
because he gave us exactly what we
wanted we wanted a championship and he
came back to cleveland
even though when he first left he went
to miami took his talent to south beach
i was
angry i was mad i never wanted this guy
ever again
i wished you know there was it was a
really bad period
for cleveland sports but when he came
back and he wrote that note that said
look i needed to learn how to be
a champion and i i understood that
and i got it and i didn't get it before
but then he came back and won us a
championship
and it was it was amazing and so when he
left the second time i was like you know
what
good for him let him pursue his dreams
let him do what he wants but he did say
we're going to make a championship for
cleveland and he did it now i'm waiting
for the indians and the browns to do it
and honestly trading mike clevenger i
don't know i don't know if you if you
want to do that like i was like wait a
second you this guy is
you you just but the thing is like the
cleveland indians like know how to make
starting pitchers like we had kluber
cooper was getting old we got rid of him
have fever have bieber and then
clevenger it's like i was like my god
the indians are like
they just breed great you got a great
manager though
i love frank kona i i you know and and
obviously something's going on with
clevenger because he went out
you know broke covered protocols and and
you know what you heard out of
the clubhouse and some of the guys that
they weren't too keen on
so honestly let's talk about that okay
sir you have an elite level pitcher a
pitcher that's doing
fantastic for you your your hitting is
not as well as your pitching is doing
uh it as a matter of fact they're not
doing any favors for any of their
pitchers
uh you know but they're they're a good
team why would you get rid of a pitcher
like that like do you
do you not think your world series bound
is that what it is like i don't know
they were eight games over 500 when they
made the deal so i mean
maybe i don't know it's again clubhouse
chemistry is
is the only thing you could chalk it up
to and if anybody knows anything about
that and how it can destroy a team frank
cona would be
at the front of that line i i i guess in
terry you you trust
basically you know yeah i i was i was a
little mixed a little big [ __ ] but they
got a bunch of future prospects which
they're very good at uh at making future
prospects into
elite level players man i love talking
sports with you hey
um i i know you haven't been on uh in a
while so
um i want to thank you in front of
everybody here
for given run rich run um and saint you
to shout out
uh as you did in your uh other work
uh as a superstar um
it really meant a lot you could see how
many people um
hit the link based on you giving a shout
out and you know you running into
the ring it really was something else i
know glaze
uh uh was for maybe buzzing in your ear
about it jay glazer
uh it just means a lot it really does so
i wanted to thank you you got a big
heart man
i love what you do each and every you
know sometimes you watch the combine and
you're like
it's repetition repetition the thing i
look forward to
is watching you run man and do that
sprint
in your suit and uh it's entertaining it
creates a lot of buds for st
jude's which is an amazing charity and
that and honestly
it's one of those things whenever you
have a platform and you're able to do
something good
in the world like i say do it and and
you're doing that
like for instance myself and uh james
roday from psych you may know him from
psychic during a little thing
we're doing a a charity with uh with uh
the nfc
where we are donating all our proceeds
every everything that that we win in
this fantasy football league
uh is going to go to connor's cure which
is a
cancer it's for pediatric cancer
research uh through the v foundation
and uh we're working really hard with
the v foundation the conor's cure and
hopefully
james and i will be able to win this
fantasy league and we can win
up to 207 000 but not only that
someone in the league said look if you
guys win the league
i will double or whatever you win i'll
double it so we have a chance to win 414
000
for pediatric cancer research so you
know it's one of those things when
you're given a platform you know i say
use it and uh we're trying to use it for
pediatric cancer well good luck to you
in that league uh in our league enjoy
zeke elliott because
that's who you're going to get i will
walking i mean honestly would you not
pick zeke elliott number three
um i don't know man nick chubb could
have a big season for those super
bowling bombers
you're a huge chump and i'm a brown fan
and i i i even
i'm just messing with you too early i'm
messing with you i'm messing with you no
zeke is
i had him last year um i'm you know uh
he he definitely would be uh the true
i'm just going to go with
saquon i think we're going with saquon's
second overall that's your that's that's
that's how we're going that's it right
you really have to i think we have that
who's first and if someone does not pick
christopher caspary number one i don't
know i might want i need to
reach through the phone and smack them
or reach from the zoom call wherever
we're doing it
yes uh it's stuff mckagan right yeah
duff has the first pick maybe
maybe we should talk up chris carson for
duff hey man
if i were you gonna go for them
hey uh thanks again for the call we'll
chat down the line i'd love to have you
on throughout the season check on your
browns check on your fantasy and just uh
check uh check out
um the uh great show cannonball tomorrow
night for the season finale on usa
september 3rd uh 8 eastern time thanks
for the call ms
thanks rich you're always amazing thanks
man right back at you
mike the miz on twitter and instagram